Si t'avais pas envie de venir fallait pas venir en fait.
Parce que si c'est pour être là et faire la gueule.
Excuse moi mais ça sert à rien.
Ça apporte rien de bien, ni à toi, ni à moi ni à personne ici.
Daccord, et comment tu peux me faire des reproches
alors que tu m'invites à une soirée pyjama entre filles ?
Enfin, c'est pire que la friendzone ça.
Ça n'a rien à voir, si je ne voulais pas te voir, je t'aurais pas invité.
Donc je suis ton pote gay c'est ça ?
C'est pas parce qu'on est entre filles que c'est une soirée Girly.
Tu vois on est entre personnes humaines, voilà, y a pas de différence en fait,
On est entre amis, entre potes.
Mais moi je veux pas être ton ami.
Camélia ! Camélia y a la scène d'amour qui commence !
On peut en parler après ?
Ouais....
C'est là, c'est là !
C'est cette scène !
N'importe quoi sérieux.
Ben pourquoi ?
C'est pas parce que tu fais des guilis
à quelqu'un qu'il a envie de t'embrasser, ça n'a pas de sens.
Ben qu'est-ce que t'en sais ?
Ben si je te fais ça t'as pas envie de m'embrasser ?
Enfin si j'fais ça t'as envie de m'embrasser ?
Non mais sérieux ? Regarde !
Arrête !
Ben non je crois pas, là je le fais et pas d'embrassade !
T'as envie de m'embrasser ?
Arrête !
Réponds, mais juste c'est une question simple, regarde,
c'est ça, t'as envie de m'embrasser ? Non !
Là, t'as pas envie de m'embrasser ?
Wooooow ! Vous faites quoi là ?!
Je sais pas c'est comme si je contrôlais plus rien quoi.
Ouais Noémie, tu peux venir par là s'il te plait ?!
Tu sais c'est quoi ça ?
Non j'ai pas fait ça !
C'est pas vrai !
Je comprends pas ce qu'il fait avec ses mains.
Qu'est-ce tu fais là ?
Je dois savoir !
Arrête ! C'est...
Non ! Pas avec moi !
Qu'est-ce que tu fais là ?
Allez !
Arrête !
Euh les filles, du coup ce qu'on va faire
c'est que vous allez comme qui dirait partir.
Putain je suis en retard !
Comment je suis sensé vous défendre moi, après tout ça Elias?
C'est le retard de trop...
Non, là on a atteint le point de non retour, je suis désolé.
Vu les évènements...
On va devoir se passer de vous.
Et à titre personnel, ça me fend sincèrement le coeur.
Ça vous fait aucun effet ce que je raconte.
Mais enfin Elias.
Ça va hein...
Attention hein.
Ah oui !
Ecoutez Elias, je peux peut-être revenir sur ma décision finalement.
Putain, mec t'es fou ou quoi ?! T'as failli m'écraser là !
T'es sérieux là ?
Mais regarde où t'as atterri, comment t'as fais pour atterrir là ?
File moi ton numéro !
Ta merde là !
Hé mec !
Ah donc tu ramènes ton pote c'est ça ?
Non, je ne le connais pas.
Tu fais quoi là ?
Elias ?
Salut.
Ça va ?
Ouais...
Ah ouais j'ai bien merdé là.
Ouais, je vois ça ouais.
Mais je sais pas en fait...
J'ai cru que j'avais une...
Une sorte de super pouvoir, comme ça avait marché sur toi...
Je me suis dit...
Ouais... tu t'es pas dit...
Ben en fait non, la fille, je lui plais, depuis le départ, parce qu'elle a des sentiments, pour moi,
et qu'elle se dit, tiens s'embrasser et être ensemble, ça pourrait être des trucs cools, non ben non.
Attends mais ça veut dire que....
Pour ma pote ?
Oui tu pouvais aussi la pécho...
Du coup...
Comme quoi tu vois on connait jamais vraiment ses amis.
Ah ta pote, oui ta pote oui, oui oui !
Ah ouais on connait pas trop trop les gens.
Ouais...
Bisou, c'est ça ?
Ben ouais... Si t'as deux minutes, tu vois...
Ouais, ben ouais grave...
D'accord. Ben...